- [Interviewer] Okay, Miena.
- [Miena] Yes.
- [Interviewer] Miena, where
are you from originally?
- [Miena] I'm from
Juarez, Chihuahua, Mexico.
- [Interviewer] So just over the border?
- Yes, over the border
from El Paso, Texas.
- [Interviewer] And what got
you out here in the skid row?
- What got me out here for skid row,
it's problems I had in Mexico
like being in the mafia and
doing all these killing.
- [Interviewer] Not you
in the Mexican mafia,
but all the violence.
- Yeah, all the violence and me in it too
when I was in there.
- [Interviewer] When you were in there?
- When I was in Mexico
either you had to be a part of
it or they kill your family.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
- Yeah. And then from there,
so I moved to Texas and I still had to go
because there were like, it's
just over the border, so.
- [Interviewer] So you were connected
with the Mexican mafia?
- Yes, yes I was connected.
- [Interviewer] And what kind of things
did they require you to do?
- Kill, kill people in front of them
to see if you really have the balls,
you really have the balls to do it.
- [Interviewer] You have
been killed somebody?
- Yeah. You have to kill somebody either,
if you don't do it, then
they go for your family.
Because you already in there,
they tell you to do something
and if you don't do it,
they go for your family.
- [Interviewer] So who did you kill?
- Oh, I kill anybody
that put in front of me.
Just anybody you grab.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Yeah. Because before we
used to be killing the girls.
Way back years ago they used
to play in girls with no head
or chop, chop up into
refrigerators and bags.
Yeah. We had to do all that.
- [Interviewer] How many
people did you kill?
- I kill like six.
- [Interviewer] Six
people. How did you do it?
With a gun or with a knife?
- No, with a knife.
- [Interviewer] With a knife.
- Knife, yeah, you just chop it off.
- [Interviewer] Men, women, children?
- No, no children. They
didn't put me in a children.
Just women or men.
- [Interviewer] And people you don't know.
- And people I don't know.
- [Interviewer] And how
do you feel about that?
How did you feel about that?
- Well at first, it was a thrill.
It was a thrill.
I had a thrill, a good feeling.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- But then now I think about
it and it's like kind of weird,
kind of, that's a feeling
weird that I can't believe
I did that in order for
me to be in the mafia.
- [Interviewer] Yeah and
you're affecting a person
and their family.
- And affecting the life, yeah.
- [Interviewer] And has
lots of wave of effects.
- Yes it does, it does.
It affects you bad.
Mentally it affects you.
- [Interviewer] It's
hard to sleep at night
with everything's going on.
- Yeah.
That's why I drink sleeping
pills to just knock me out
because everything goes
back to you comes back
and you can't sleep.
I mean, you're, you gotta
be watching like your back.
- [Interviewer] Well you
grow up you were, in the end
you're given an ultimatum
of either do this
or they'll kill you.
- Yeah or your family.
- [Interviewer] Or your family.
- Yeah, that's true.
And it's a rough life.
- [Interviewer] So you escaped?
- I escaped.
I went to, I came over here.
- [Interviewer] So El Paso
was not far enough away?
- No, it wasn't far enough
because it's just the border.
- [Interviewer] So you can still?
- Yeah, they could still get you.
At first it was so easy to pass
by, to pass over the border.
So and then they got people
on the other side to looking for you.
I mean, if they put the green light on you
that means that you're gone.
- [Interviewer] Wow. How
many years ago was this?
- This was like 20 years, 30 years ago.
20, 30 years ago, that's
when I was still young.
Now I'm 55 and now I think more better.
I mean, not more better
because I'm still doing drugs
and it's not a good feeling.
What else can I tell you?
It's real, it's real only.
It's real only.
What is, it's getting better
but still the gangs, they don't end up.
They're still there.
Violence, a lot of violence up there.
That's why sometimes I'm
kind of scared to go back
because everybody put
the green light on me.
- [Interviewer] So if they finds you?
- Yeah, I'm gone.
- [Interviewer] So, you got family?
- Yes, I got family here.
- [Interviewer] Children?
- Yes, I got five children.
Four living, one passed
away in a car accident.
And my youngest one is 16 years old.
- [Interviewer] Who's
raising the 16 year-old?
- Grandma, my mom.
She's raising her.
- [Interviewer] And your family is safe?
Your family is safe?
- Well, cause they're over here.
- [Interviewer] Oh, they're here?
- Yeah, just my mom's over there.
So they're not really safe.
So she has to be hidden.
She's a very old lady.
She has to be a hidden.
- [Interviewer] Hidden?
- Hidden like hiding.
- [Interviewer] Hiding, yeah.
- Because if they find her,
I mean, they could kill her
either it's me or my family.
All my other sons are here in Los Angeles.
My sisters are here
and only my mom and my youngest
daughter is over there.
So yeah, I've seen a lot of
children. I mean, it's bad.
- [Interviewer] And so you have friends
that are in the same situation
who kind of got recruited by the Mafia?
- Yeah, recruited by the mafia.
- [Interviewer] And they
require to do the same thing?
- Yeah, they would require.
Once you're require,
once you do what they tell you to do,
you're already in it and
it's hard for you to get out.
Because you already know all what they do,
all their hangouts.
Where they got the, all the drugs,
where they have everything.
- [Interviewer] After
you've killed somebody,
How does it affect you?
The following days?
Weeks after killing?
- At first, it didn't affect me.
It sure didn't affect me.
It didn't affect me.
I had, I got like a thrill on it.
- [Interviewer] Really?
Yeah. I had a good feeling at first
but now it's affecting me.
Mentally it's affecting me,
but I'm going through it.
I'm kind of scared to go back
because they're still violence over there.
There still violence, a lot of violence,
a lot of killings still, I
mean, it's not going to stop.
- [Interviewer] So you're
using drugs, heroin?
- Oh yes, I'm on heroin opium.
- [Interviewer] How long
has ever been doing?
- I started when I was 13
years old, stop here and there.
I stopped like, I stopped
when I go to prison here.
I went to prison in Texas.
I went to prison.
They had to isolate me.
- [Interviewer] Isolate you?
- Isolate me because
I had the green light.
- [Interviewer] Oh, so they knew?
- Yeah. See, so everybody
knew on the green light.
Because it's just over the border.
- What did you do in prison,
you're still, you're marked.
- Yeah, you're marked. You can't hide
so that's why they gotta
put you, solitary yourself.
Yeah. And it's kinda scary.
I mean, now it's scary,
at first it was fun.
It was fun killing.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Sure it was fun killing.
- [Interviewer] You know, there's like a
- No I don't.
That's what people tell me
but I did seven years for one life.
- [Interviewer] In Mexico?
- No, in Texas.
- [Interviewer] In Texas.
- That's what I did my
time, seven years in there
that's when they put me in solitary.
- [Interviewer] So one of
your murders was in Texas
or all of them are in Texas?
- No, there was some in Mexico.
Now, just the one I did
time for, it was in Texas.
For seven years I did.
- [Interviewer] So now you're
on skid row, kind of hiding?
- Kind of hiding.
- [Interviewer] Where do you
live? Where do you sleep?
- I sleep in my tent.
- [Interviewer] You have a tent?
- I have a tent that I bought
but it's still kind of scary.
I put chains and locks in there.
I mean, you got that shell in there,
somebody's up there and get you.
It's a bad feeling.
- Which is more disturbing being in Juarez
or being here in skid row?
- Oh no, being in Juarez.
- [Interviewer] Yeah it sounds like.
- Being in Juarez, yes.
- [Interviewer] It sounds really horrible.
- Yes, it is horrible.
And before that when we were
chopping people's heads up,
the woman's, a prostitutes women
because we didn't like all
that prostitution in there.
Sometimes they give you some
kind of disease or everything.
So what we used to do
is we see a prostitute
that used to like point at you.
You take care of that and
you already knew what to do.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- They didn't have to
explain to you what to do
or nothing. You just.
- [Interviewer] What happens?
You walked to them and.
- Yeah, just go out and
you're in front of everybody.
It don't matter because the
people in Juarez are scared.
They're scared of the mafia.
- [Interviewer] They won't report you?
- Yeah, they won't report you.
So they just tell you, point you out,
get that one right there or
the one on the other corner
and you know what to do.
So yeah, they were used to do that.
And after that, like nothing happened,
like very everything's cool.
- [Interviewer] There
weren't presence of the ward.
- No, nothing.
- [Interviewer] Nothing.
- Nothing. Just keep doing
what we're doing and,
but I got tired of that life
so I kind of, wanted to stay out of it
but it's kind of hard to leave it.
- [Interviewer] How do you
escape thing or leaving?
- What could, they could kill you.
I mean, you're gonna be
dead before you leave them.
- [Interviewer] So you will be dead?
- Yeah, You're already in
there, you're stuck in there.
- [Interviewer] You can't leave?
- You can't leave.
- [Interviewer] So you left.
- So I left and I'm still hiding.
I'm right here in skid row,
lonely, but I'm hiding.
Yeah. It's kind of rough.
- [Interviewer] And what
do you do for money now?
- Shoplifting like earlier this morning.
I went to the stores.
I went to go steal some clothes.
That's what I do for my living.
- [Interviewer] Have you been
in jail here in skid row?
- Not really. 70, 78.
78, 79, I got for shoplifting.
Yeah, but it's just like 72 hours and out.
- [Interviewer] You don't look
like a shoplifter either, so.
- No, that's very, I
mean, I try to look decent
not because we're in skid row.
I mean, we're gonna let
ourselves throw, like look.
- [Interviewer] You don't
look a heroin addict.
You don't look like a hit man.
You don't look like a shoplifter.
- I guess that's really good.
- [Interviewer] You look somebody's mom.
- Yeah I am. I got five, four kids.
- [Interviewer] And you
still have contact with them?
- No, because there, they
could hear or something.
- [Interviewer] So you came
in contact with nobody?
- No, you can't contact or
nothing because they'll find out
where your family is and where you are.
I mean, they got a lot of connections.
You could imagine yourself,
a lot of connections.
- [Interviewer] Oh sure.
- Even here, whatever state.
Yeah but when I was with
them, I was kind of young.
I looked different and I
kind of like paint my hair
or living with gray hair or
- [Interviewer] They
give you virtualizing up.
- No, not really.
I mean, they will because of my face,
like the innocent of me, I guess.
The innocent of me that's
how they could tell.
I mean, I had rid of, take
out my tattoos from there
on my neck, my face, I had
tattoos and everything,
I took them off the reason
for, because of that.
So a lot of killings over there.
- [Interviewer] So as
a child, as a teenager
and you did this, you got
involved with them at what, 13?
- 13 years old.
- [Interviewer] So as a young teenager,
were you already kind of a normal kid
that was getting into trouble?
- Yes, I was stealing.
- I'd like to steal when I was young
but now it was like 11, 9
years old, I was stealing.
- [Interviewer] So
you're already, kind of?
- Yeah. I was already
messed up, messed up.
- [Interviewer] And why was that?
Tell me about your childhood.
- I can't blame nobody.
Probably, I was finding some kind of love
from somewhere else and I
found it and I got stuck there.
- [Interviewer] Tell me,
your parents, two parents.
- No, just got my mom.
My mom, she's leaving.
She's 84.
- [Interviewer] And
where she is? She's in?
- In Texas.
- [Interviewer] She's in Texas.
- She's hiding, like that passed away.
Got my sisters here.
The reason why I ended up in skid row is
because I don't want them,
to get them in trouble.
- [Interviewer] What would you like to say
in your family if you could?
- That I love them.
That I love my kids.
And I miss you, mom.
I wish I could go back home
but sooner or later I will get sick.
And sisters, thank you for
everything you guys doing
and thank you for taking care of my mom.
And I thank God too. I thank
God for still having her
but can't get her, can't hug her.
I mean, I love my daughter.
Because of that what I got
into it when I was young,
I mean, it's a bad feeling.
Sure it's a bad feeling.
But at first it wasn't.
At first it wasn't, I
mean, at first it was good.
It was all good and everything.
But now, I mean, you
feel that's behind you,
you can't sleep.
I mean, your head's messed up.
- [Interviewer] Do you still
worry at night or whatever?
- Yes, I still worry.
- [Interviewer] About
somebody who finds you?
I still worry.
I do, I still worry a lot.
Sometimes I don't even sleep.
Like, I got locks in my
tent, I put like three locks
and the inside, I put
two, one on the outside
and I just have to tell my
neighbor open the outside
and that's how I kind of get out.
- [Interviewer] How many
years were you with them?
- I was like 20 years with them.
- [Interviewer] 20 years?
- 20 years.
20 years, I started being with them.
- [Interviewer] And what kind
of other deeds did you do?
- Just killing. That's the way it to do.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- Killing. Just killing.
Because we used to have
all the merchandise.
We used to have merchandise
and we used to give it to
somebody. And if you don't bring
the money that you're supposed
to bring, you're dead.
They'll point you out, take care of that.
They'll just say, take care of that.
Take care of that.
I mean, it was kind of rough
especially when we're killing
the ladies, the girls,
the prostitutes, even the homosexual,
there was a lot of children
from homosexuals too.
Just chop them up at night.
- [Interviewer] Sometimes you'll
be killing somebody who did
something wrong or whatever,
not necessarily a prostitute?
- No, not necessarily a prostitute.
- [Interviewer] To be anyone.
- Anyone, anyone they point you to.
Anyone they point you to
they just tell you what to,
take care of that.
- [Interviewer] They
generate a lot of money?
They're powerful?
- Yeah, they're really powerful.
I mean, they're really powerful
because they buy the police over there.
That breaches there, I mean,
that breaches with our mind.
So if I didn't like, you
wouldn't come through.
Because we used to run the
line from Juarez to Texas.
And we didn't want you
walk them over here.
Sometimes they, we used to find,
they used to bring bodies from
Texas to Juarez in the trunks
just to stash them away
on this side, all bodies.
- [Interviewer] What's the most
horrible thing you've seen?
- The most horrible thing I've seen
is when they torture this lady.
They did it by cutting her eyes
and you had to see what, you're there,
you've got to see what they're doing.
- [Interviewer] They forced you to watch?
- Yeah, you gotta watch. You gotta watch.
- [Interviewer] So once
she's alive they remove?
- Yeah, little by little, make her suffer.
Take one thing out and
then another thing out.
Just to, I guess to feel that thrill,
that feeling that we feel
when we're killing somebody slowly.
At first, it wasn't real because
when you take one eye out, very niche.
Oh and you take something
else out, ear, a finger
or even your balls or I mean
just to make you suffer.
- [Interviewer] And you
would do this sometimes?
- Sometimes I would do it.
I mean, yeah, because they point you out.
- [Interviewer] And you
gonna have no choice?
- You gonna have no choice.
You've got to do it.
Or else, you're going to get in it.
I mean, I haven't been over
there for about a year.
For about a year, I
haven't been over there.
- [Interviewer] So you
went back a year ago?
- Yeah. I went back, but
I couldn't get too close.
The reason why?
Because they were looking for me.
- [Interviewer] Do you wear disguise?
- I got that. I had a wig,
blonde wig, some big glasses,
a hat, some woods, I
mean like a cover one.
I got to disguise. I disguise myself.
I went up to Houston but
I didn't stay there long
because I didn't want them
to spot me or you know.
- [Interviewer] Even in Houston?
- Even in Houston,
wherever, you just have to,
I just went and back.
It is. It's kind of rough.
You got to, it's a value in weather.
Here in Texas, what I give my seven years.
Because they still had that thrill on me.
So I went and go ahead and kill this man.
Just for the fun of it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
already know where to do it?
- No, just for the fun of it
but to feel that thrill on me
and I didn't run, I did nothing.
It's just, I just felt good.
I mean, that good feeling that I had
and that was my last killing I did.
So now I'm wanted over there.
- [Interviewer] You're what?
- I'm wanted over there in
Mexico or El Paso anywhere.
They find me, my life is gone.
Like I say, it's better
my life than my family.
Yes, that's it for now.
- [Interviewer] Miena, thank
you for sharing your story.
- You're very welcome.